Whenever we conduct a research study and compute statistical results, we report
those results in something called a Results Section. So, I'm going to outline a
little bit what goes into result sections. The first thing we put in our result
sections are descriptive statistics, for example the mean in standard
deviation. The descriptive statistics represent the heart of our study, this
tells us exactly what happened in out study and should always be reported. And
we can report those in three ways. We can report them in text. In other words,
we put them right in, in between our words in our results section. We can put
them in graphs, such as a bar graph. Or we can put them in tables. Next, we'll
want to report our inferential statistics. And this is either a hypothesis
test, or a confidence interval, or sometimes both. So when reporting a
hypothesis test, you want to give the reader the following pieces of
information. You want to tell the reader, what kind of test did you conduct?
For example, a one sample t test. Next, you want to give the actual value of
the test statistic. For example, the value of t. Then, you provide the degrees
of freedom of the test, not the formula, but the actual number that comes from
the formula. You also want to give the reader the p-value, specifically the
exact p-value, if possible. Next, if applicable, give the direction of the
test. For example, is it a one tail test, or a two tail test? And always
provide the alpha level. Always let the reader know what alpha level you used,
to make your decision. For many disciplines, we use APA style to report the
results of our hypothesis test. APA stands for American Psychological
Association. The APA has a whole guide on writing research papers and one of
the parts of that guide, tells us how to write inferential statistical results.
I'm going to give you a brief introduction to APA style for statistics, as it
relates to the T-test. So, here's a generic outline of how to present the
results of a t test in APA style. First, we put the test statistic name, in
this case it's t. Next to that, we put the degrees of freedom in parentheses.
We put an equal sign, then we provide the t value, rounded to two decimal
places with a comma, then we give the p value. Again, rounded to two decimal
places. There are some exceptions in this rule, but for the most part, this is
how you do it. And then, we put out the comma and we tell the direction of the
test whether it's one tailed or two tailed. I'll give you a more concrete
example in a little bit. Imagine the situation in which we have a t value with
24 degrees of freedom equals negative 2.50. If we're doing it by hand we only
know whether the p value is less than or greater than 0.05, and we have one
tailed test. This is how you'd write it out. If we used a computer to get these
results, we'd end up with an exact p-value. An exact one tailed p-value for
this situation rounded to two decimal places is 0.01. So, in that case, we can
actually put p equals 0.01.